officials from FEMA were on the ground
over the weekend meeting with community
members and assessing the damage and
FEMA administrator Deanne Criswell was
on that visit and joins us now from
Alexandria Virginia administrator good
morning thank you for being here
good morning yes yesterday secretary
mayorkas and I had an opportunity to
travel to Rolling Fork and assess the
damage firsthand and I was able to talk
to many of the individuals that
experienced just what you saw in the in
the previous clip and it's devastating
this is a town that is very close-knit
everybody knows each other and even
talked to somebody that was in that
restaurant that as soon as they got out
went back home into their neighborhood
to help people that were in their homes
and get them to safety I'm really
heartbreaking but also inspiring to see
how this community comes together to see
how all of the neighbors came out to
help each other
what concerns you the most right now
we are going to have a long-term
recovery on our hands here and we are
going to be able to to be on the ground
with them and support the state of
Mississippi I talked to Governor Reeves
extensively about some of the things
that he's going to need housing is going
to be our biggest issue and we are going
to work with the governor and his team
to make sure that we are finding
Creative Solutions to help this
community rebuild and what we can do for
them in the interim to give them some
type of Transitional Assistance and a
safe place to stay
I just heard you say Miss Criswell
long-term recovery do you have a
timetable on that what exactly does that
mean and what will FEMA do right now for
these people but what's your what does
long-term recovery mean let's take that
part of the question first
yeah I mean we are going to have to
rebuild this community right we're going
to have to rebuild the homes we're going
to want to make sure that people stay in
this community everybody that I talked
to said they want to live here this is
where home is and so we want to make
sure that not just rebuilding the homes
but making sure that these small
businesses get back up and running that
we get the infrastructure back up and
operational so people don't leave and
they do stay and we give them that safe
place that they can Live While We're
rebuilding the businesses rebuilding
this community and hopefully making it
safer more resilient against future
tornadoes so you're talking months years
oh definitely months and into years to
really get this community back to normal
but it's going to be better than ever
everybody was so inspired and they have
great hope about what's in store for
them in the future as we continue to
work with them during this rebuilding
process
hope is what they need administrator
Nate here we know that these
catastrophic weather events are
happening more frequently but we also
know that over the last handful of years
there have been more billion dollar
disasters do you have the funds to keep
up with these very costly disasters
uh you are you're so right that we are
continuing to see an increase uh in the
number of severe weather events that are
happening across the country right now
we have the funds to support the initial
response operations that are going on
right here within Mississippi but we're
going to need to work with Congress to
make sure that we do have the funds to
support the ongoing rebuilding for This
Disaster and additional disasters that
may come throughout the year
administrator Criswell thank you so much
they definitely need hope and help we
appreciate you